let me tell you this before I say
anything else this is going to be one of
the last episodes of this series and how
many more arms going to make after this
I have no idea that all depends on my
speed in detail placement because one
thing that I am planning on doing in the
last couple of episodes and I know that
this is probably not going to be the
best let's play material but then again
the premise of this entire thing is that
i'm going to share every single thing
that I've done in a certain part and
exactly that has happened in this well
except for the a couple of seconds that
I may or may not have forgotten to put
in the video a couple of times many
times probably but I'm sure that won't
happen in the future anymore and now the
thing that I need to you think about
right now is what I'm going to do after
this pike and I have actually settled on
the idea of making floating island
Baltic park and if I would like that
it's a really stupid idea it really
feels like the stupid idea factor that
this bike has but I'm I'm that serious
about this because that was one thing I
wanted to do it's make a floating island
Pike because I I mean it's not a really
unique or original idea and many people
have actually tried it before but rarely
anyone has ever finished one or I have
never actually seen a finished floating
island roller coaster a park or
something like that so I definitely want
to try that and the other thing the bell
take scenery idea is because I've never
seen that I've seriously never seen a
Baltic themed ride or pork and I know
that there may be some out there but
it's just a theme that barely anyone
tries kind of like I have rarely seen an
Indian the theme as in those Indian
temples and stuff like that and yeah
there's just certain themes that nobody
tries and I don't want to try it just
for the sake of trying it it there's all
sort of like that it just looks great
and I really want to see how I can make
that looking in Monaco second three and
one thing that I'm worried about is
whether it will actually look good on
floating islands whether that will
actually fit the setting but I suppose
it will now to talk about the things
that I'm doing in this video actually
probably something that I should be
doing in the first place I decided that
on this place which I had left over here
this empty spot I would just place this
building and this building turned out to
be an experiment fest and sometimes you
need to do that you just need to go into
your custom scenery stuff and look at
things you've never used before and see
if there's anything you can use in there
and that's exactly what I did with this
building and you know it's something
that I'm somewhat conflicted about
normally I'm not but then again this is
a let's play and I probably shouldn't be
working on things that I don't have any
experience with because as you may know
the thing that I usually do is before I
start recording I just start building a
random stuff getting the hang of custom
scenery sets and generally how a theme
works so i actually have a better piece
of building stuff and i can actually
draw ideas from that but i didn't do
that this time around just simply
because i didn't feel like it whatever
and that is something that i will do
though with my own Baltic Pike so it may
take a while until I start on that and
like I said once again it all depends on
how fast i am with detail placement on
this park because although this point
may look very finished and it definitely
is very close to finish the only area
that really needs to be done still is
the area near that flat ride insanity
thingy because there's still an empty
wall over there and yeah I need to work
on that but one thing that I also want
to do is just go all over the park see
if I can add more details here and there
see if I can improve things and I want
to keep that I want to keep doing that
as long as I feel like the park is not
perfect or kind of because I'm not going
to work on this park for five years I'm
well aware that I'm already working on
this park for nearly a year now I think
not too sure about that but very long
time and you know as fun as it still is
doing this and of course since it's a
pike and I know that the entire Pike has
many themes but every time it's still a
little bit different so it's still fun
to work on something but after a very
long time and I'm sure that everyone in
the roller coaster and three communities
felt this you just need to work on
something new and that's the kind of
idea that I feel right now
and a Baltic theme is going to be
something new as really jumping into the
deep but I really want to try this theme
and that's what I'm just going to do it
now I still also want to do something
with an asian idea so I might turn that
into coaster or something else and right
now I'm actually thinking of abandoning
the idea of doing a roller coaster
tycoon 3 shenanigan serie because I feel
like that's obviously not going to work
out and and the main focus in my opinion
should still be rollercoaster tycoon 3
and not whatever commentary or something
like that people want to watch somehow
now what I might actually do though is
here and there between uploading let's
play videos upload videos that are
called time lapses and you might be what
your let's play videos are already time
lapses and yes that's true but I feel
like I work on so many projects but i
can't show any of them that i feel like
i could sometimes just throw random
timelapses on my channel and be like
here here you go no the time lapse this
is something that I'm working on you can
see it right now cool and I might also
do more streams on youtube because i'm
streaming very often on twitch and i
know that i don't have a huge following
over there but it's just such a much
more friendly medium than YouTube which
is extremely terrible and yeah because
chat delay and general worse streaming
but then again the audience is bigger on
YouTube and stuff like that so it's kind
of a dilemma where I should three so I
might actually do some more streams on
youtube in the future but not all
depends on whether I feel like it that's
a good way to would it but that's really
what's going to happen and I know that
in the past couple of weeks i haven't
uploaded too many videos I i do want to
start blending more videos again because
you know that there was there were just
certain things i got a cold so i can
record and then I went to Austria so I
couldn't record and in Austria I got
another call BAM so I could barely
record and that's just things that have
been stopping me and then the school and
you know life so I'm sorry about that
but I want to start uploading bit
more again and yeah I should probably
talk about this building and I don't
know what I don't know what to say about
this is it's just the same old thing
just kind of tying into the theme of the
main plaza over here although I must say
that I think the main plaza is looking a
lot better thanks to this small building
aveo which doesn't have too much of an
impact but that that front thingy is
just so sexy and thank you station gym
for being such an awesome custom scenery
created and while we're on the topic of
custom scenery and i know i've been very
off topic right now but that's because I
haven't done this commentary in a very
long time okay I've lots of things to
talk about there is a thing that came
out a couple of days ago and if you
haven't seen it check it out because
roller coaster tycoon 3 is never ever
going to be the same ever I will
probably post a link in the description
or something like that if I don't forget
it which I'll probably will so in which
case you'd probably have to go too well
look it up or tell me that I forgot
about the link and then i'll post it but
basically everyone knows the europa park
anons and their amazing titties and how
they revolutionized the game but then
again the cts weren't all that smooth
and you didn't have any inversions and
they were coaster types that nobody gave
a [ __ ] about anyway so yeah the impactor
was kind of mad in that respect and not
too many people are using them at the
moment but the pep team is working on a
new CT which is rather than being a CT
on its own it's actually a kind of
expansion on the in-game interment track
and it's it's a Bluefire CT and it's
quite ingenious little thing because
what it does is it gives you extra
pieces for the in-game intimate track so
for example a curve that starts out flat
and ends with the bank similar to the
extended coaster in Monaco Tekken 3 and
some amazing inversions and just all
around cool over banked turns and very
awesome elements so that CT is
definitely going to revolutionize the
game and i'm pretty sure that as soon as
that thing is going to come out everyone
is going to start spamming that thing
everywhere and it will be the newest fad
so yeah I said I suppose you you all
have to prepare for that one
and yeah this is where I start placing
details because I still couldn't start
on that one empty area because the thing
that I'm planning for that area is a
flat ride but then again I i still
haven't installed any flat rides I I
went into I went on the internet lost
time and got some flat rides installed
them and install them like an idiot and
nal ever I can't even pronounce the
words and basically no SPD for SI d turn
up and I was mad and removed the custom
flat rides again so now I'm left with 0
things to place over here so I still
need to install things work in a couple
of buildings as a backdrop for this
thing and then the awesome detail work
start and um I don't know for sure but
I'm guessing that somewhere between
either three or six more episodes this
park is going to be finished which 66 is
going to be an extreme maximum I'm going
to aim for three but knowing me i'll
probably take a lot longer and i suppose
i can actually make a decent guess of
how long this park has taken me because
that's one thing I do like about doing
let's play you can follow your own
building of a park yourself and I know
that might sound stupid and useless but
it's a fun measure to actually see how
long it took you to build the pike
because now I can I can just go to all
my videos count up all the minutes and
multiply it by eight and then I should
about half the time it took me to built
the spike so that's actually really cool
and I'll dig into that later and I'm
already thinking about the video editing
of this because I'm planning on adding
my own music currently writing my own
OST for it on and off though it's taking
a very long time to write every single
track and I still suck at mastering so
that sucks and I also want to try some
video editing techniques because my
video editing I know that some people
like it but I'm still not too happy
about it and I definitely want to
instruct to try and improve it so I'll
see what I can do with that and I had
the idea that I might want to try slow
motion
stuff in roller coaster tycoon 3 so I
went to my nvidia panel and got
recording software and other things and
see if I could actually get a high FPS
andronico's second 32 record in slow
motion but no that's not true the roller
coaster tycoon 3 is locks at 30fps for
some stupid reason and I got over a
thousand at minecraft but that was
pretty useless so now i'm going to try
some other methods to see if i can add a
slow-motion effect so going to make my
own ctrs and set them to a very slow
speed and see if that looks like slow
motion but anyway that's it for this
episode so thanks for watching